NICK COUSINS OUT UP FRON
FIRST TWO SHOTS OF GAME THREE
ND
BOTH GUYS YOU SEE AND GOOD SHOT
FINDS ITS WA
MAKAR.
SHOT BLOCKED IN THE E AND NATHA
MacKINNON AT THE TOP OF TH THEN
TOEWS.
LEHKONEN HAD A GOA.
DUCHENE UP ICE.
FEEDS IT OFF TO HIS LEFT. THAT
GOAL.
>> Shane: QUICK EXIT UP THE ICE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A LOOSE E  OUT
THAT YOU'RE FOCUSED IN THE
MOMENT AND THEN YOU CAN GET  IN.
LEHKONEN COULDN'T PLAY T WITH O
START IT OUT.
LEAD PASS OFF THE SKAT CARRIER N
AND FEEDS IT BACK DOWN T.
THEY ARE GOING TO PLAY CATCH.
THIS IS A PLAY BY EKHOLM.
HE GOAL LATEY TO THE
AND SCORE!Y DIFFERENT WAYS.
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THA
THEIR CAPTAIN ROMAN JOSI.
WHAT YOU LIKE ABOU>> Dave: KADR
AND SCORE! ON THE WAY
IT. CREASE.
LANDESKOG AND Ma
PUCK TRICKLES LOOSE FOR JOSI.
ROMA.
LANDESKOG BRINGS IT BACK.
OPEN EYES.
STRIKING DOWL FIVE PREDATORS.
THAT LEAVES THAT LANE WITH A
QUICK PASS AND T
THIS ONE Dave: PUCK LOOSE OFF T
FACE-OFF.
NICHUSHKIN MOVES
>> Shane: THEY CERTAINLY ARE.
FOR THE PREDATORS, THIS ONE